a message from western powers to beijing
stop the human rights abuses against
ethnic and religious minorities
or there will be a price to pay a
coordinated set of sanctions from the
united states european union
britain and canada against several
chinese officials
who are now subjected to a travel ban
and asset freeze
for their alleged role in human rights
abuses
against muslim uighurs in northwest
china
the eu's foreign policy chief says the
sanctions are meant to engage beijing in
dialogue
rather than change its policies and
address our legitimate concerns
china has against turned a blind eye
and these measures are regrettable
and unacceptable there will be no
change in the european union
determination to defend human rights
and to respond to serious violations and
abuses
as i said irrespective of where
they are committed it infuriated beijing
who almost immediately issued
retaliatory sanctions of their own
against several european politicians
they said were spreading lies and
misinformation
china has repeatedly denied human rights
abuses are perpetrated against religious
and ethnic minorities
but u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken said china is guilty of genocide
against uyghurs
and the sanctions come just days after
contentious meetings
between chinese and american officials
in alaska
but on monday the white house said the
sanctions are
not a direct reaction to the alaska
meetings
obviously this was a reaction to
what we felt were serious human rights
abuses obviously the europeans felt this
as well
against members of xinjiang's ethnic and
religious minority groups and no meeting
would change our concerns
related to that and we took action as
you noted in unity with the united
kingdom
canada and the european union who also
acted against human rights abusers in
connection with these atrocities
you know this demonstrates our ongoing
commitment to work multilaterally
to advance respect for human rights and
we continue to have great concerns about
china's crimes against humanity and
genocide on uyghurs
in xinjiang under former president
donald trump
the u.s took a unilateral approach to
all things
china that has clearly now changed under
president joe biden
the way to do this is certainly not to
do it unilaterally but to do it with a
coalition of other countries and this is
the first time
that the united states has worked
together with its allies the eu
and canada and the uk to jointly slap
sanctions on china and it is a signal
that there are many countries that find
china's policies and xinjiang to be
unacceptable
reprehensible they are violations of
human rights
and and china has to start rethinking
its
approach the sanctions are largely
symbolic
and on their own likely won't be nearly
enough to change
beijing's behavior but with china set to
host
the winter olympics next year the
sanctions do
mark a shift of western powers returning
to
speaking to beijing with one voice when
it comes to human rights
and now tensions could escalate
gabriel zondo al jazeera washington
well